اول شيء
خطاب رئيس كان يساهم فيها الكثيرون هذا
على مداء سنوات حكمه الكل طبعا بصفتي تلك
وزير مدير الديوان الرئاسي كنت اشرف على
التنسيق
الخطب وتفاعل مع رئيس الجمهوريه عندما
يطلب ان يضيف شيئا او ان نعدل شيئا او ان
نحسنا فكره او نطرح برنامج او مبادره
وكانت خطوبه في المناسبات الوطنيه
ونبدا بالاخير لان الخطاب الاول همم كتب
وانا غير موجود يعني يكون في مهمه خارج
الرئاسه
وائل الخطاب ثاني بتاع يوم تسعه
عدلته ناسه وقراته والى اخره وكان ختابا
يعني لم يكن
بالخطاب الذي اطرح اشكاليه خطاب يوم 13
بالنسبه للخطاب الاخير قلت لك يوم 13
كلمني الرئيس حتى انزل الى جنبه للمكتب
قال انه هنالك كلمه يريد ان يلقيها همم
في الوضع الذي كان سائدا ان ذلك في البلاد
ولم
تحولت الى مكتب الرئيس
وجدت ان هنالك مشروع
فيما بعد علمت ان المشروع
اعده حكيم القروي وهو
اتصالي واطار تونسي يعيش في الخارج فرنسا
على ما اظن
ومش هنتكلم
باللغه العاميه
والخيار والكتابه بالعربيه
ما نعرفش بالضبط
[موسيقى]
على علاقه باسهر الرئيس
لا اظن همم
لا مناقشه الخطاب الاخير صار الرئيس كان
منهم سي مروان مبروك
وشفنا الكلمه الى اخره
اضاف هو الرئيس انا ذاكر
بعض الاشياء يعني مثلا مساله تكوين لجان
للتحقيق في التجاوزات واللجنه
لتحقيق في الفساد
المالي ولجنه اخرى للتحقيق
للتحولات السياسيه او الدستوريه وللاعداد
للانتخابات سابقه الاوانها والاخير هذا
ذلك
لا لا بقيت في الجلسه يعني اثناء عرض
المقترحات هل كان هناك من يرفض مثلا مثل
هذه المقترحات ان يدرج الرئيس مثل هذه
الامور
لم يرفض احد
وحضرتك يعني كتبت ساهمت في كتابه جزء من
هذا الخطاب
العمود الفقري للكلمه